Harvard Law School alumni Texas Senator
Ted Cruz you know it's interesting um I
had debating on this program two
professors from Harvard one a Democrat
that thinks you were one of his best
students of all time that would be Alan
dershwitz the other uh Cornell West
who's running for president and I said
at the end of that debate Senator that
the sad part is this debate that we had
on this show we would not be able to
have at Harvard we reached out to them
they never got back to us uh and I think
that speaks volumes what is your
reaction to your Alma Ma look it it is
disgraceful how Harvard is behaving I
got to say claudian Gay's testimony was
the worst testimony I've seen in the 11
years I've been in the Senate you had
her testimony you had the president of
pen you had the president of MIT the
president of Penn has already resigned
in disgrace I think all three should
resign in disgrace not a one of them
could give a simple clear answer not a
one of them could categorically Den
denounce anti-Semitism categorically
denounce genocide against the Jewish
people and not a one of them could
figure out whether calling for mass
murder of Jews violates their harassment
policy it was ridiculous and there's a
reason why did Claudine like listen to
all of these people defending Claudine
Gaye well she was surprised what do you
mean she was surprised the entire topic
of her testimony was on this and the
reason she gave that answer is that she
sides with the protesters she is a
radical leftist she is a cultural
Marxist you talk about my book unwoke
how to defeat cultural Marxism this is
cultural Marxism they Define Jews as
oppressors they Define Palestinians as
victims and the cultural marxists
support the violent revolution of the
victims against the so-called oppressors
and the result is because the three of
them are leftists they are cheering for
the h terrorists it is disgraceful and I
got to say at Harvard you are seeing
Jewish students being harassed being
threatened at MIT you're seeing Jewish
students afraid to go to class and these
leftists are unwilling to stand up and
defend their students she should resign
and I got to tell you I think there are
thousands upon thousands of Harvard
alums who are horrified at the behavior
of the institution right now you know we
often talk Senator about identity
politics uh what if the genocide of and
then fill in the blank had to do with a
particular race or a particular sex or
against anyone in the lgbtq community or
what if genocide of uh a person uh with
gender identity uh issues or what if it
was genocide against people that believe
in Islam uh I think there'd be a very
different reaction on campus so the
students would be expelled immediately
if you called for genocide of any of
those groups who the left defines as
victims you would be expelled
immediately but because they view Jews
in the context of Israel as oppressors
you're allowed to abuse them look
USC banned a Jewish Professor from
coming on campus it was an economics
professor who anti-semitic protesters
threatened and USC ordered him to teach
his entire class remotely for the year
you know my podcast verdict with Ted
Cruz yesterday's podcast is entirely on
this Harvard testimony and just how
disgraceful it is and and and for the
Harvard Corporation to say we stand
entirely with our president you know
what it you know what it's saying it's
saying we're okay with anti-Semitism we
don't want Jewish students to feel safe
on our campus and by the way claudian
gay in that same testimony she was asked
about that the percentage of Jewish
students that is plummeted on Harvard's
campus and she said I I don't know I
don't know how many Jewish students are
there which is a flat out lie these Bean
counters they know every
transgendered
left-handed whatever they know that but
yet they claim they don't know how many
Jewish people are on campus this is an
institution and by the way Harvard going
back to the
1950s Harvard had in place what were
called the Jewish quotas where they
capped the number of Jewish students
allowed in because on Merit Jews were
doing really well and getting good
scores and good getting good grades and
they said Harvard said we don't want to
many Jews and they put quotas in place
and so for her to claim now she doesn't
know how many Jews are there and she's
apparently not troubled that Jews feel
threatened because she's willing to
contribute to the rhetoric that is
undermining the safety of her own
students and by the way to be clear I
don't mean safety from comments that are
difficult to hear I mean safety from
physical threats we've seen videos of
Jewish students at Harvard being
harassed being threatened physically and
I got to tell you if any student
physically threatens another student
that student should be expelled whether
they're Jewish or Muslim or what have
you universi should protect their
students these leftists won't do that
unrelated topic uh you really went after
Senator Dick Durban uh for protecting
those people flying on Jeffrey Epstein's
plane the Lolita Express as it's called
Uh for not wanting to subpoena the
flight logs that would give everybody
the names why is he unwilling to get
those flight logs look it's an awfully
good question he a Fox news reporter
asked him in the Hall of the Senate why
dick Durban and the Senate Democrats
were blocking the flight logs of Jeffrey
Epstein's planes and he claimed I don't
know anything about it I wasn't there I
don't know about it on my podcast
yesterday I played the video and said
yes you were there you're the one it was
my colleague Marsha Blackburn she
introduced an amendment that I joined
that would have subpoena the flight logs
and said we need to see who was on that
plane if they're a prominent politicians
who were involved in in molesting young
girls we need to know don't protect them
and I got to say the Democrats are
freaking out he literally blocked all
amendments and in my view Republicans on
the Judiciary Committee we ought to keep
pushing to say we're going to vote on
the record if you are covering up for
someone who is engaged in molesting
children we're going to expose it and I
will say Sean do you know what painting
Jeffrey Epstein had hanging in his
living room in Manhattan I don't he had
it's it's really horrible he had a
painting of Bill Clinton in a Blue Dress
wearing red pumps high heels hanging on
his wall it's traumatizing if you Google
it you're going to hate the image that's
what Epstein had on his wall maybe that
explains why dick Durban and the
Democrats don't want a subpoena those
flight logs they're not going to like
what they find in him Senator Ted Cruz
of Texas thank you hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else